bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
jeudi
la révolution des tulipes fait basculer
la kirghizie des milliers de partisans
de l'opposition se sont emparés de la
présidence et de la télévision
quelques affrontements mais aucun coup
de feu n'a été tiré
le président akaïev a pris la fuite les
célébrations du jeudi saint de pacs sont
déroulées en l'absence du pape jean paul
ii trop affaibli a suivi la messe à la
télévision dans ses appartements
on n'a jamais vu on n'a jamais vécu
aussi vieux en france pour la première
fois l'espérance de vie a dépassé le
seuil symbolique des 80 ans hommes et
femmes confondus une française sur cinq
qui n'est aujourd'hui sera centenaire la
loi du silence battu en brèche au procès
du nationaliste corse charles pieri à la
barre l'ancien pdg de nouvelles
frontières jacques mailhot a dénoncé le
racket quand il a été la victime
six de ces agences avaient été visés par
les attentats
l'asie du sud se relève lentement du
tsunami il y aura trois mois après
demain que le raz-de-marée a dévasté les
côtes nous sommes retournés en thaïlande
avec des familles françaises à kaolack
où la page est encore loin d'être
tournée
enfin encore un champion du monde à la
retraite le gardien l'équipe de france
fabien barthez 33 ans annonce qu'il
mettra fin à sa carrière l'an prochain
après la géorgie après l'ukraine c'est
encore une ex république soviétique qui
fait donc sa révolution démocratique ou
pas il est encore un peu tôt pour le
dire en quelques heures 15 ans de
pouvoir ont été balayés en kirghizie le
président akaïev a été chassé de son
palais par la foule
bernard lebrun étonnamment rapide une
matinée aura suffi pour renverser le
président akaïev au pouvoir depuis 15
ans dans cette pauvre république d'asie
centrale de cinq millions d'habitants
ce bunker dans la capitale appelée
maison blanche siège de la présidence et
du gouvernement est tombé en quelques
heures aux mains des manifestants
incroyable image que celle de cet
opposant assis dans le fauteuil même du
président dans ce même bureau il y a
deux jours askar akaïev interdisait aux
manifestants de se rendre dans la
capitale
le fauteuil est vide à kayes a disparu
une folle chevauchée donc que ce jeudi
du printemps kirghizes à l'image de ce
cavalier qui brandissait tôt ce matin
les couleurs de l'opposition face à face
des forces anti-émeutes non armés
ceinturant la présidence et des
opposants avec des pierres et des bâtons
ils police non offensive qui fait
mouvement au milieu d'une place
abandonnant la garde de la présidence
puis qui chargent à cheval les
manifestants
bien sûr on comptera une trentaine de
blessés mais pas un seul coup de feu
tiré
et puis surtout comme par magie les
grilles de la maison blanche vont
s'ouvrir aux manifestants
au mégaphone l'un des leaders de cette
opposition kourmanbek bakiev ancien
premier ministre ancien gouverneur
libéral dit ont influencé par les
amériques a peut-être le parlement
kirghize s'est réuni en session
d'urgence nommant un président par
intérim et la cour suprême a annulé les
élections législatives contestées de
mars enjeux du soulèvement
hormis quelques pillages les rues
semblent être calme ce soir à bichkek et
le parlement vient de donner 24 heures à
l'opposition pour former un gouvernement
avec les résines des plus petits textes
république avec un peu plus de 4
millions d'habitants trois réactions
la france se dit préoccupé elle appelle
au dialogue c'était en début d'après
midi avant que le nouveau pouvoir
s'affirme l'ambassadeur des états unis
lui apporte ouvertement son soutien à
l'opposition
quant à la russie elle appelle à un
retour à la légalité et à l'ordre au
vatican les cardinaux les évêques les
prêtres et les fidèles ont vécu pour la
première fois un jeu 10,1 de pâques sans
le pape
une absence de loups heureusement
ressentie par l'assistance jean paul ii
a dû rester dans ses appartements arômes
gérard griesbeck claude gagnon comme le
cristal avait les pieds
acteur de ses 12 apôtres selon les
évangiles le cardinal colombien ce soir
répété les mêmes gestes
un signe d'humilité qui commémore la
cène le dernier repas de jésus
cela fait plusieurs années que jean paul
ii ne procédait plus au lavement des
pieds mais c'est la première fois qu'il
est absent de la cérémonie
absents aussi ce matin de la messe où il
en a consacré les saintes huiles qui
serviront toute l'année aux sacrements
sur la place saint-pierre les pèlerins
savent qu'ils ne verront pas le parc
avant la bénédiction de dimanche il faut
que je suis déçu triste de son absence
c'est comme une fête familiale laissant
le père de famille
demain soir le pape sera également
absent du chemin de croix au colisée
l'an dernier encore il était là même
s'il ne pouvait plus marcher demain une
vidéo retransmettra peut-être l'image
d'un pape muet en ces cérémonies de
pâques
rarement un absent n'aura été aussi
présent en bref monaco retient son
souffle l'état de santé de régnier ne
connaît aucune amélioration c'est ce
qu'a déclaré à l'agencé france presse
une source proche du riverain ses
enfants on va percevoir caroline
continuent de se relayer à son chevet le
prince reste sous assistance
respiratoire
je vous le disais en titre on n'a donc
jamais vécu aussi vieux en france
l'espérance de vie à la naissance a
dépassé en 2004 l'an passé le seuil
symbolique des 80 ans hommes et femmes
confondus un peu plus pour les femmes un
peu moins pour les hommes elle a gagné
10 mois en deux ans c'est beaucoup
la progression s'accélère parce qu'on
mange mieux parce qu'on fût - et parce
qu'on est mieux soigné en guérissent
amiez loup à 15 jours et elle a une
chance sur deux d'atteindre 94 ans une
sur vingt même d'être centenaire c'est
que l'espérance de vie croît à une
vitesse vertigineuse en deux ans hommes
et femmes ont gagné dix mois
supplémentaires pour atteindre une
espérance de vie de 80 ans
la france compte 3 millions dopé génère
et souvent au mieux de leur forme
on vit plus longtemps grâce notamment à
la prévention et au meilleur traitement
des maladies vasculaires et aussi depuis
peu grâce aux progrès dans la lutte
contre la mortalité due au cancer du cou
en deux siècles et demi
l'espérance de vie a triplé au xviiie
siècle elle est de trente ans à peine
une meilleure hygiène de vie au 19ème
elle atteint 40 puis 50 ans dans la
première partie du 20ème siècle on meurt
en moyenne à 60 ans et c'est à partir
des années 50 qu'elle fait le grand bond
le niveau économique s'améliore et on
introduit les antibiotiques moins de
maladies infectieuses moins de mortalité
du coup en 2004 quinze mille français
deviennent centenaire alors jusqu'où
peuvent nous mener
les progrès de la médecine on y re pas
prévenue par la prévention des maladies
au delà de 90 ans
on est à 80 rappelle tous sexes
confondus et qu'après il faudrait agir
sur des mécanismes même du
vieillissement
danielle darrieux belmondo gréco des
artistes pour lesquels le temps n'a pas
de prise et si la recherche fondamentale
fait encore des progrès on pourra avoir
sait-on jamais des centenaires aux jeux
olympiques
oui à 81 autrefois on était un vieillard
aujourd'hui très souvent la vie continue
voici l'exemple de marcel rainaud
il a 78 ans très exactement deux enfants
trois petits enfants et il continue à
exercer son métier de manadier en
camargue il s'occupe des taureaux et des
chevaux comme s'ils avaient 20 ans ou
presque
reportage véronique ghiglione pascal
pons pour moins de thé pour moins de th
si je peux avoir une petite butte qui
met deux buts et je me le pied sur la
butte déjà ça vous aide mais il faut
qu'on peut l'accepter à cheval je suis
parti commun comme il ya 20 ans
nous ne sommes pas des
l'un à 60 18 ans l'autre 76 et les deux
frères ne parle pas de retraite les
chevaux et les taureaux les occupent
plus que leurs rhumatismes c'est une
recette de longévité dans la famille
depuis quatre générations
cinq ans à la fin des temps qu'on peut
tenir droit on veut continuer maintenant
on va voir on va voir l'avenir sous le
support des coups de cornes
la vie en a donné mais il ne se plaint
pas pourvu que la camarde l'oubli un peu
plus en camargue
il se voit bien centenaire toujours
utiles sur ses terres est ce que vous
sentez le poids des années ou pas je
fais le matin au réveil la terre des
jours où il ya le coup de rouleau le mot
qui ne marche pas problème il faut
sauver j'ai pu apprendre les pas offrir
on y pense - une vie au grand air sans
tabac et sans trop d'alcool
voilà le secret de bonne santé de marcel
et puis surtout il a très vite arrêté
l'école pour selon lui ne pas perdre de
temps mais ça bon faut pas le dire
devant les enfants
voyez pas forcément un exemple à suivre
quand même justice avec une journée
attendue au procès du chef nationaliste
corse charles pieri un homme s'est
présenté à la barre pour dénoncer le
racket ça n'est pas si fréquent on a vu
beaucoup de témoins se désister il
s'agit de jacques mailhot l'ancien pdg
de nouvelles frontières
il a tout raconté les attentats les
menaces compte rendu d'audience yann
fronty mathias marbre ils sont arrivés
ensemble pendant des années ils ont été
les responsables de nouvelles frontières
l'un des principaux voyagistes français
jacques maillot avec une écharpe rouge
en était le pdg jean christian pineau
derrière le directeur général des
témoins clés très attendue du procès
pieri visiblement à l'aise
une oraison détendue
au début des années 90 les deux hommes
ont décidé de se lancer dans le tourisme
en corse
très rapidement des attentats ont visé
leurs agences un peu partout en france
six explosions pour la seule année 1993
un message clair du racket il fallait
payer pour travailler en corse à la
barre jacques mailhot l'a reconnu
parlant clairement souvent avec humour
il a raconté comment il avait été obligé
de sponsoriser le club de football de
bastia ou encore de payer des encarts
publicitaires dans le journal
nationaliste ou ribombu pour qu'il n'y
ait plus de bombes devant le juge
d'instruction jean christian pinault
avait désigné jean guy talamoni l'un des
chefs de file du mouvement nationaliste
comme étant l'instigateur de ces
d'extorsion de fonds il est ensuite
revenu sur ses aveux
face au tribunal aujourd'hui il ne l'a
pas désigner nommément
il a juste répété que quand ils se
croisent et il se comprenait une phrase
ambiguë pour jean guy talamoni
l'accusation ne tient plus vous des je
crois que les prétendues charges se sont
effectivement effondré et pas seulement
pour moi je pense que chaque observateur
ici a pu se rendre compte de l'ampleur
de la manipulation
dans son box charles pieri semble
toujours aussi détendu amusé même par la
tournure des débats
après plus de quinze jours de procès
toutes les zones d'ombré les ambiguïtés
de ce dossier ne semblent toujours pas
levé même si le racket et les extorsions
de fonds semblent désormais établie on
ne sait toujours pas précisément qui en
a profité durant toutes ces années
autre procès celui de jean pierre roux
durafour l'auteur de la tuerie de tours
qui avait fait quatre morts et sept
blessés
après les experts psychiatres hier sa
famille était appelé à la barre depuis
le début de l'audience vous le savez il
récuse toute responsabilité il invoque
des trous de mémoire et bien pour la
première fois aujourd'hui il a un peu
infléchi sa position caroline gauthier
guillaume michel sortie d'audience pour
les familles des victimes rencontre l'ex
femme de jean pierre honduras
vraiment
à la barre joël du g n'a rien caché
pendant 1h30 elle a dit sa haine sa
colère sa rancoeur
mon dieu s'il ressort une recommence pas
question on est d'accord que l'ouverture
du procès mercredi au complot mais
toutes les deux et il est venu s'excuser
à la place de son mari parce que fab et
qu'il ne ferai jamais
le face à face entre l'accusé et celle
qu'il appelle aujourd'hui encore sa
femme est accablant pour jean-pierre ou
duras pour joël du g raconte ses années
de vie commune aux côtés d'un homme
dangereux jaloux violent l'envi de tuer
il avait depuis longtemps
explique-t-elle il m'avait dit un jour
je ferai un carton et ça se saura tout
est calculé
même la mener son ex mari se lève tout
est vrai à 98% affirme-t-il en la
regardant les parties civiles apprécié
la défense beaucoup moins avec le
témoignage de mélanie et fabien deux des
trois enfants de l'accusé le ton change
mélanie nenê tente de défendre son père
intelligent est sympa mais qui pouvait
selon elle devenir complètement barré
aujourd'hui jean-pierre ou durafour est
un peu sorti de son amnésie évoquant
quelques flashs je me vois sautillant
dans la rue j'ai tiré sur une forte
un blouson vert ce sera tout il ne
craquera pas ces témoignages étaient les
derniers demain les plaidoiries
commencent les parties civiles tout
d'abord avec une douzaine d'avocats
la semaine prochaine le réquisitoire
puis les plaidoiries de la défense le
verdict lui n'est pas attendue avant
mardi dans la soirée
toujours à propos de justice on en parle
et hier sachez que les parents des cinq
enfants laissés dans un dénuement total
et privés de nourriture ont été reconnus
coupables par le tribunal de bobigny le
père âgé de 34 ans a été condamné à un
an et demi de prison ferme
la mère à un an ferme les cinq enfants
sont confiés à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance
le procès de la catastrophe du mont
blanc lui s'est interrompue pendant une
journée puisque on commémorait
aujourd'hui le sixième anniversaire du
drame les familles des 39 victimes se
sont recueillis devant le mémorial sur
la rampe d'accès
au tunnel à 10h55 très précisément
l'heure à laquelle l' incendie s'est
déclaré
les sirènes ont retenti tout s'est
arrêté deux minutes de silence ont été
observées reprise du procès demain le
gouvernement a lancé aujourd'hui une
campagne de sensibilisation pour le port
de la ceinture de sécurité à l'arrière
le réflexe apparemment n'est pas encore
acquis sept passagers sur dix seulement
la boucle régulièrement entre guillemets
des messages radios ont été présentés
des affiches aussi ainsi qu'un spot
assez cru vous allez le voir thomas
rambo laurent des bois dans ses deux
ceintures
qu'est ce que je faisais at il dit
quatre amis à bord d'une voiture quoi de
plus anodin
vous allez trouver un passager ne
portait pas sa ceinture
le spot est à l'image de la réalité
violant la ceinture de sécurité est
obligatoire à l'arrière depuis 15 ans
pourtant un passager sur deux la
négligent jusqu'ici les autorités ont
toujours été laxiste peu de pv est
tellement de bonnes raisons de ne pas la
boucle et comme on est un peu serré pour
avoir un peu plus d'aisance projet n'est
gelé pour mu
on sent sécurisé par les par les sièges
à l'avant et ne pensent pas simplement
un trajet très long on va les attacher
plus que lorsqu'on a un vrai jeu court
erreur la majorité des accidents mortels
se produit dans un rayon de 15 km autour
du domicile des victimes pour les
enfants à l'arrière sans ceinture le
risque d'accident mortel est multiplié
par six à 50 km/heure un enfant de 5 ans
devient aussi lourd qu'un projectile
d'une tonne on sait aujourd'hui que
entre un passager qui reste dans
l'habitacle en cas d'accident et à
passager éjecté le risque de mourir va
de 1 à 10 faire preuve de fermeté telle
est la consigne transmises aux gendarmes
et aux policiers
désormais la responsabilité du
conducteur sera engagée pour ses
passagers qu'ils soient majeurs ou pas
il sera passible d'une amende de 145
euros
et ce jeudi était aussi la journée de la
courtoisie au volant
sixième du nom journée organisée par
l'association de prévention des
comportements alors nous avons tout
simplement procéder à un petit test à
marseille
choses vues et entendues dans la rue
c'est sans commentaire de nos jours dans
matthieu pouces
ça vous arrive de commettre des
incivilités au volant oui souvent
c'est à dire
régulièrement passer à l'orangé de voir
au fond rouge pour essayer d'être nommé
à gauche alors qu à droite
est ce que ça vous arrive de vous
énerver au volant n'ont jamais non
jamais été son témoin non pour moi
j'avais cinq ans quand la route quelque
chose sur une armée non mettre en avant
des bus
et vous avez un gros mot favori au
volant cana marseille en dessous des
[ __ ] avance idiot voilà
ça vous arrive de commettre des
incivilités au volant il faut dire aussi
que la circulation était
particulièrement difficile aujourd'hui à
marseille en raison d'une grève des
transports en commun une grève qui
portait sur la future gestion du tramway
les ministres de l'intérieur et de la
justice faisait le point aujourd'hui sur
la sécurité dans les quartiers
difficiles
plus précisément il ya quelques mois un
plan pilote concernant 25 quartiers
avaient été lancées mobilisant tous les
acteurs de l'état les policiers les
magistrats les professeurs les
éducateurs alors nous avons cherché à
savoir si derrière les mots il y avait
ensuite les résultats
l'une de nos équipes s'est rendu à
l'ousse des bois à pau quartier marqué
vous vous en souvenez peut-être par des
affrontements et une série d' incendies
de voitures apparemment il y a du mieux
reportage david d'asie philippe kemel
côté face l'ousse des bois à pau c'est
un quartier populaire comme les autres
où l'on vit tranquillement le facteur
qui connaît chaque palier même très
attaché à sa tournée
personnellement quand j'y passe en tout
cas tout va bien quatre côtés sombres de
jour comme de nuit l'ousse-des-bois
subit régulièrement les affrontements
entre bandes du quartier et policiers
des poussées de fièvre qui ressemble à
celle de certains grands ensembles de la
banlieue parisienne alors que
l'ousse-des-bois est un petit quartier
de 2000 habitants les six mois de façon
cyclique l'avait il y avait des
dérapages très très important il ya eu
il ya eu mort d'homme il ya eu des coups
de feu tirés contre la police un
incendie de l'hôtel de police en plein
jour ce qui n'était jamais arrivé
en france en 2003 l'attaqué à la bombe
incendiaire du commissariat par des
jeunes gens cagoulés est un tournant
dans la vie de l'ousse des bois classé
désormais dans les 25 quartiers les plus
sensibles de france police justice et
services de l'état conjuguent leurs
efforts pour arrêter les auteurs
présumés mais aussi pour démanteler le
trafic de drogue d'ampleur nationale
dont vivent les bandes du quartier
à partir de ce moment là je pense qu'il
ya eu une espèce de réflexion de la part
de ces gens du quartier qui se sont dit
bon c'était pas la peine d'essayer de
continuer dans cette voie là
ils sont peut-être partis ailleurs
répression mais aussi destruction des
immeubles les plus vétustes
à la place la ville finance ces
habitations individuelles ou collectives
parce que c'est un petit pavillon
qu'éminent y en un jardin c'est à n'y a
rien à dire
et pourquoi selon vous bon parce que des
gens qui l'habitent et qui c'est qui
habitait en d'aménager un nouveau
commissariat a été construit avec ses
grilles et ses bornes anti voiture
bélier il rappelle que la mutation de
l'ousse des bois reste toujours fragile
la contre attaque des partisans du oui à
la constitution européenne c'est le
débat désormais qui domine toute la vie
politique française et tout est bon pour
faire valoir ses positions
exemple ici avec la ministre des
affaires européennes claudie haigneré à
la rencontre des clients de ce
supermarché à paris où elle a distribué
le texte de la constitution
accueil plutôt courtois et il y avait
autant de caméras que 2k 10,1 millions
d'exemplaires du traité seront mises à
la disposition du public dans les 6000
magasins de ce groupe
valéry giscard d'estaing lui présentait
un petit livre explique mans à la
constitution européenne aux éditions dan
un livre destiné aux enfants mais que
tout le monde pourra consulter
l'ancien président rappelons le est un
des pères du traité et il n'a pas mâché
ses mots
les arguments du camp du non prennent
les français pour des imbéciles dit-il
avec de faux procès fait par de faux
témoins
le débat européen qui a complètement
phagocyté aussi le congrès annuel de la
fnsea les agriculteurs on en parlait
récemment il serait franchement
favorable au non d'après les sondages
du coup les partisans du oui les leaders
politiques se sont bousculés
la tribune pour tenter de les convaincre
sur place au mans arnaud bouteille
guillaume vient il n'était pas invité
mais ils font le plus de bruit devant
les portes du congrès les lycéens
manifestent contre la loi fillon
à quelques mètres un autre sujet
inquiète c'est la pac et beaucoup
d'agriculteurs votre nom le 29 mai
prochain le vote non risque d'être un
vote de sanction qui ne compte plus que
le fond de lui-même de la constitution
un par un les leaders politiques
arrivent pour tenter de convaincre cet
électorat
il faut leur parler comme des citoyens
et des acteurs économiques qui savent
bien que leur destin est en europe pour
leur dire la vérité et je pense que ce
qui est vrai pour les agriculteurs il va
également pour les français à
l'exception du communiste alain bocquet
trois chefs de parti françois hollande
françois bayrou nicolas sarkozy trois
fois oui sur la même tribu et bien moi
je veux une europe politique avec un
président identifiable et identifié une
robe tient visage une europe on pourra
dire c'est lui le responsable
et c'est lui qui rendra des comptes et
bien si vous voulez de cette europe il
faut voter pour la constitution lorsque
jean pierre raffarin arrivent les bayrou
sarkozy ne sont plus là et le premier
ministre se permet donc une petite pique
vous avez pu entendre ce matin une
partie des candidats donc à ma
succession
mais comme puis il appelle à voter oui
avec le nouveau traité la voix de la
france sera plus forte et plus on donne
de place à la politique plus on donne
deux places à la france pour cette
première grande tribune du oui
le départ se fait par la petite porte
une discrétion obligatoire pour cause de
manifestation et le malaise est bien
perceptible à l'ump peut être plus
encore au parti socialiste où les
divisions sont étalées au grand jour
malaise au sommet malaise à la base
aussi dans le tarn l'une des fédérations
historique celle de jean jaurès
reportage de vie imbert edouard perrin
au sommet du parti les hollande dsk
fabius et autres mélenchon peuvent bien
continuer à se contredire dans le ps
d'en bas la machine s'est mise en marche
les militants collent des affiches et
eux ils n'ont pas d'états d'âme
pourquoi on n'y croirait pas c'est pas
un texte parfait mais c'est un texte qui
amènent des avancées
rien n'est jamais tout blanc n'est
jamais tout noir donc ce texte il est
plutôt gris clair des adhérents qui
croit la constitution la fédération ps
du temps on en a compté 55 % référendum
interne de décembre un résultat net
comme au niveau national
et pourtant aujourd'hui ici comme
ailleurs le débat n'est pas tout à fait
clos je suis pour le oui/non
même avec le sourire dès qu'on entre
donc dans le vif du sujet c'est toujours
la discorde il suffit par exemple
d'évoquer l'inévitable directive
bolkestein cette directive
à mon avis elle était dans les tuyaux la
constitution la directive je suis choqué
profondément choqué que les gens ne
respectent pas les règles du parti
accepte que les gens soient mécontents
que quand ils voudront sectionné et chez
pac et le gouvernement c'est le député
s'appelle paul quilès l'un des amis de
laurent fabius favorable au non ils se
plient à la discipline du parti
mais n'en pense pas moins il m'a pas
demandé comme chez staline à l'époque
cap en donnais mes convictions ou de
dire le contraire de ce que je pense
paul quilès votre a nommé restera donc
discret lui contrairement à ce qu'ils
font ouvertement campagne pour le non
les uns et les autres en tout cas n'est
pas à la clarté du message socialiste
dans cette campagne
le mouvement des lycéens perd encore de
sa vigueur cette nouvelle journée
d'action était marquée par le blocage le
blocage d'une centaine d'établissements
un peu partout en france ici à toulouse
blocage qui n'ont
d'ailleurs pas toujours été du goût des
élèves de terminale le bac ce dans deux
mois et demi seulement les
manifestations elles ont rassemblé
quelques milliers de personnes à paris
quelques centaines à bordeaux et 1500
environ ici toujours à toulouse image de
notre correspondant isabelle de lyon et
nicolas aubert et à propos des cols les
sanctions se multiplient contre les
élèves qui prennent un peu trop de
liberté sur leur blog un blog vous le
savez si vous êtes familier d'internet
c'est un journal pas vraiment intime
puisque tout le monde peut le consulter
sur la toile un bloc notes en quelque
sorte
beaucoup de lycéens avaient pris
l'habitude de juger leurs professeurs
avec des termes parfois insultants
l'éducation nationale a décidé de sévir
dominique team bakala olivier robert ils
les ont sur leur téléphone portable
rires la nouvelle attraction des
collégiens et lycéens la photo de procès
entre dans ma cruz ne me vois pas dans
ma trousse saison les photos certaines
de ces photos se retrouvent parfois sur
des blogs
comprenez journaux intimes sur internet
selon l'éducation nationale 50 % des
élèves participent à ces forums de
discussion améliorer l'accès facile
chacun petit allait de son commentaire
et personne ne se gêne tel est injuste à
une tête de chouettes lautrec une saleté
de profs à la peau et parfois les
messages sont encore plus radicaux la
semaine dernière huit collégiens ont été
exclus pour des propos similaires dans
la somme en auvergne et dans ce lycée de
garges les gonesse en banlieue
parisienne
quand les élèves ont été prises en
flagrant délit la sanction a été
immédiate disproportionnée selon
certains de leurs camarades
pour lui c'est une plaisanterie je vais
rigoler les produits l'avait pas
d'arrière pensée pour les 3es je faisais
pour plaisanter récent voyeur par
internet entre copains entre copains
mais internet est un espace public et
des injures sur le web ça tombe sous le
coup de la loi
hélas on vous inviter des gens et que
l'accès public même si il y à une
adresse pour s'y rendre
on est bien dans un endroit public a
priori on est sur un régime de
responsabilité tout à fait classique et
insulté un prof c'est de la diffamation
ça peut coûter jusqu'à 12000 euros
damende publié une photo sans
autorisation c'est porter atteinte à
l'image
il intéressait peut vous réclamer des
dommages et intérêts en bref le
oco texas aux états unis une très forte
explosion dans une raffinerie de texas
city l'une des plus grosses du pays a
fait 15 morts et une centaine de blessés
l'hypothèse d'un attentat a
immédiatement été écarté la piste de
l'accident est privilégiée il a fallu
deux heures pour éteindre l'incendié
retour maintenant en asie du sud il y
aura trois mois ce week end que les
côtes ont été dévastées par le tsunami
en thaïlande les autorités et la
population très vite déblayer avec
énergie mais il reste quelques zones
pratiquement en l'état a kaolack par
exemple où certaines familles françaises
revenu sur place n'ont toujours pas fini
avec les démarches et donc avec le deuil
reportage philippe rochot bruno carette
trois mois après le tsunami rien n'a
vraiment changé au sofitel de kaolack
tous portent encore la trace de la
catastrophe du 26 décembre qui a fait
230 morts ici une famille qui a survécu
à l'essai ces images de la terrible
vague qui a submergé l'hôtel sur plus de
10 mètres et emporté les corps disloqué
par la force de l'eau jérôme passer noël
ici avec ses trois enfants
la vague les à noyer dans leur chambre
il revient sur les lieux du drame avec
trois autres français qui tous ont aussi
perdu approche ici et s'interroge sur la
façon dont la catastrophe a été géré
vous savez je suis parvenue depuis trois
mois de mai la raison essentielle je
vais me recueillir à l'endroit où sont
formés les trois enfants ça fait des
semaines qu'on leur demande de récupérer
des effets personnels vous avez vu ça a
été l'hôtel était complètement pillée il
a été laissé à l'abandon depuis
aujourd'hui j'ai recherche suis retourné
en les chambres évidemment enfin ils ont
commencé à nettoyer votre aide mais j'ai
retrouvé quelques petits effets
personnels et évidemment sans valeur et
c'est un petit peu aussi pour ça je
voulais revenir ici
jérôme et les familles des victimes
arrivent au moment où l'on ferme
officiellement le centre de tacots a pas
cette pagode qui a accueilli les
milliers de corps de la baie de kaolack
à présent les containers sont tous
regroupés près de l'aéroport de phuket
afin de rendre les identifications plus
efficace non seulement donc il faut
examiner les corps faire les
prélèvements qui est un travail vraiment
vraiment difficile parce que ça passe
par le lavage des vêtements
ensuite un contrôle de qualité de tous
les deux tout ce qui était fait donc de
toute toute la chaîne de toxines et donc
il ya un dernier protocole de contrôle
qui va être fait pour l'en sur le décor
avec la mise sous scellés à l'heure
qu'il est les corps de 23 français ont
été identifiés sur 64 considéré comme
mort
mais il est capital de savoir que tout
corps non-identifiés appartient aux
autorités thaïlandaises
d'où la volonté d'accélérer le processus
la mobilisation autour de florence
aubenas et hussein hanoun aujourd'hui
dix journalistes français anciens otages
étaient réunis au trocadéro à paris ils
ont appelé les ravisseurs à sortir de
leur silence
aucun geste mais dérisoire ont souligné
les anciens captifs en direction de
l'opinion
notre consoeur de libération et sont
vides sont retenus en irak depuis 78
jours maintenant et à noter ce soir dans
envoyé spécial à reportage exceptionnel
une équipe a pu suivre pendant deux
semaines le travail d'une brigade anti
rapt à bagdad
envoyé spécial à partir de 22h55 avec
françoise joly et guilaine chenu
l'ouverture officielle de l'exposition
universelle au japon on en parlait dès
hier une manifestation placée sous le
signe de la protection de la nature et
les invités vedettes étaient fameux
robot fierté de la technologie japonaise
ils sont considérés là bas comme deux
compagnons domestiques il marche il
parle un peu ils dansent aussi alors le
public pourra découvrir les différents
pavillons paix demain la france a choisi
le développement rural comme thème
central visite guidée avec alban me
posiez alain dupas
l'empereur du japon ne sortent pas
parents ne sont pas laid l'impératrice
presque jamais c'est dire toute
l'importance que l'archipel a voulu
donner à la cérémonie d'ouverture
121 pays 5000 invités et un seul message
solennel
et mon souhait le plus sincère cette
expo ne sera réussie que si elle
démontre aux visiteurs du monde entier
l'étroite relation homme nature et
qu'elle les pousse à trouver des
solutions dans ce concert des nations
tous veulent afficher leur bonne volonté
la france et l'allemagne partagent le
même pavillon avec en vedette ce théâtre
d'image les visiteurs observent la
manière dont l'homme peu à peu détruit
la planète
un film de 14 minutes keaton comme un
réquisitoire et coline aumard grâce à ce
film j'ai bien compris que chacun à
notre niveau
même les plus modestes nous dégradons
notre environnement le reste du pavillon
français présente des solutions
pratiques tri de déchets énergies
alternatives
l'idée générale est que face à l'urgence
toutes les bonnes volontés compte j'ai
gagné et moi tout seul un est temps que
je sois le maire d'une grande ville
je ne peux rien faire alors en revanche
je prends un homme d'affaires
une responsable associative nous allons
marcher ensemble et à ce moment là vous
allez voir que nous allons avoir une
action pour la réduire les gaz à effet
de serre et mettre en vigueur le
protocole de kyoto sur un territoire
vaste comme un arrondissement parisien
chaque pays voudra aussi faire valoir
ses intérêts industriels ou touristiques
qu'il n'est pas toujours sûr que
l'environnement soit au coeur des
présentations constater qu'en matière
d'environnement le monde ne va pas bien
c'est une chose proposer de réelles
solutions
c'en est une autre c'est en substance ce
que jacques chirac viendra dire ici dans
48 heures il sera le premier chef d'état
étranger a visité l'exposition
universelle
une nouvelle tentative pour élucider
l'un des grands mystères du xviiie
siècle le destin tragique de la grande
expédition de marque la pérouse dans le
pacifique
on a retrouvé les débris de son navire
mais jamais aucun signe du navigateur
patrice que les ans de grâce 1788 deux
bateaux l'astrolabe et la boussole
partie de ciney remonte vers les îles
salomon à travers la tempête
on jette les encres mais rien n'y fait
le premier navire coulé médiatement le
deuxième un peu plus loin après trois
ans nerfs et 150 mille kilomètres
parcourus la plus grande expédition
cartographiques et scientifique
commandé par louis saez vient de
disparaître avec à sa tête le plus
fameux lieutenant de vaisseau de son
époque
jean-françois galaup de lapérouse
ce naufrage est un mystère mais 39 ans
plus tard en 1827 une goélette piloté
par le capitaine irlandais peter dillon
retrouve ceux ci une poignée en argent
frappé d'une fleur de lys une garde bp
qui ressemblait exactement unia dp
européenne en 1999 l'association salomon
seront sur l'île de vanikoro le lieu du
naufrage
surprise à terre on découvre un camp une
partie de l'équipage a donc survécu dans
la glaise du verre et des céramiques de
macao sont retrouvés c'est un camp de
gens qui essayaient
qui essayait de revivre dans un endroit
du monde qu'il ne connaissait pas en
2003 en mer un crâne est exhumé envoyés
à l'institut de recherche criminelle de
la gendarmerie
il va révéler ceux ci voici probablement
le visage de celui qui était le peintre
de l'expédition
gaspard duché devant si le 18 avril
prochain 120 scientifiques et militaires
équipés des moyens les plus modernes
prendront une nouvelle fois la direction
de vanikoro un budget énorme pour
reconstituer le destin tragique de
l'expédition lapérouse l'environnement
et la sécheresse une région fait figure
d'exemple en matière de gestion de la
provence et son fameux canal là bas on
fait des réserves chaque année le
système d'irrigation des terres et gérer
l économie marseille et la ville
d'europe qui dispose de la plus grande
autonomie six vitesses christophe l'anc
et la vanne d'eau disponible en
permanence deux années de sécheresse
n'ont pas et soif et ses terres
provençales
cette plante là c'est du temps pour
laquelle n'ont pas de problème la
sécheresse pose moins de problème
puisque nous avons à l'abord d'une cale
de province qui nous donne de l'eau tant
qu'on en veut suffit de payer la facture
jusqu'à 600 euros pour arroser un
hectare 80 mille hectares la moitié des
terres cultivées en provence sont ainsi
préservé de la sécheresse dans les
aciéries gageure quand on veut apporter
un mètre cube au chant ben il faut en
prendre 10 dans le milieu naturel
nous quand on veut apporter un mètre
cube dans le champ on en prend 1,10 dans
le milieu naturel
c'est dans le verdon que le canal de
provence puis ce sont nos et si la
rivière ne suffit plus le lac de
sainte-croix dans les
alpes-de-haute-provence fournit une
réserve de 250 millions de mètres cubes
il n'y a jamais eu problème touche
vocale de brosser pour nous y grimpe en
2003 quand il a fait très sec
nous avons livré tous nos clients nous
avons pris que 10 % de la réserve
le débit est ajustée tous les quarts
d'heure c'est par une gestion très
économe des ressources en eau que le
canal de provence approvisionne les
consommateurs une goutte d'eau qui part
en tête du canal va être utilisée par
arnaud les consommateurs avec les
réserves du canal de provence marseille
est toujours vue en france la ville la
mieux équipée
face à une pénurie d'eau l'espace est
cette nouvelle découverte de planètes
hors système solaire ont été directement
observée pour la première fois on
connaissait leur existence depuis une
dizaine d'années grâce aux calculs et
parce que leur ombre avait été aperçu eh
bien ces derniers jours c'est un
télescope spatial munis de caméras
infrarouges qui a capté ces premières
images sophie mais elle laurence de
l'heure cela fait dix ans que les
scientifiques attendait ça en 1995 il
découvrait pour la première fois
l'existence d'exoplanètes c'est-à-dire
de planètes tournant autour d'une autre
étoile que le soleil
mais cette découverte n'était validé que
par des preuves indirectes par l'ombre
portée au moment où les planètes passer
devant leur soleil voir cette fois le
télescope spatial spitzer a pu détecter
directement la lumière de deux planètes
c'est difficile de réaliser l'avancé
phénoménal que nous avons fait depuis
dix ans nous avons découvert 130
exoplanètes
mais jusqu'à présent nous n'avions que
des preuves indirectes de leur existence
ces planètes se situe à 500
années-lumière de la terre soit 150
mille milliards de kilomètres ou encore
un million de fois la distance de la
terre au soleil
ce sont des grosses planètes gazeuses
comme jupiter dont la température
avoisine les 1000 degrés mais le pari
des astronomes dans les années à venir
va être de découvrir une planète
rocheuse une planète y ait les mêmes
caractéristiques que la terre
le problème est évidemment beaucoup
beaucoup plus difficile la terre est
beaucoup plus petit
les planètes de type carré sont beaucoup
plus petit et donc il faut développer
des moyens d'observation encore plus
puissant et qui sait peut-être un jour
découvrira-t-on quelque part dans le
cosmos une planète qui abrite elle aussi
la ville les sports avec un nouveau
champion du monde à la retraite le
gardien de l'équipe de france fabien
barthez 33 ans annonce qu'il mettra fin
à sa carrière l'an prochain c'est le
neuvième sur les onze de l'équipe
titulaire en 98 à faire cette annonce
une annonce au goût un peu amer manuel
tissier des ligues fossard en dépit de
son allure toujours décontracté fabien
barthez a du vague à l'âme
en pleine préparation du match contre la
suisse après demain le gardien des bleus
annonce un peu amer qu'il prendra sa
retraite dans 18 mois en 2006 j'arrivais
en fin de contrat avec marseille dit il
j'aurai 35 ans ça suffit
barthez semblent gagnés par une certaine
lassitude et ses dernières péripéties
n'arrange pas les choses
le 12 février à casablanca barthel de
dos avec un bonnet noir craché sur un
arbitre marocain malgré la menace d'une
lourde suspension dans quinze jours
barthez ne regrette rien moi je sais ce
qui s'est passé je ne me sens pas
coupable
ce n'est pas du tout important cela ne
représente absolument rien cet épisode
et ses déclarations ne grandissent pas
le joueur fabien barthez exemplaire
jusqu'ici le chauve préféré des français
a brandi tous les trophées en club comme
en sélection
s'il n'est pas suspendu barthez peut
encore réussir sa sortie en disputant
une troisième coupe du monde
en bref le bout du chemin pour maud
fontenoy elle est attendue ce week end
dans les prochaines heures en fait aux
îles marquises en polynésie
la jeune navigatrice est donc en passe
de devenir la première femme à effectuer
la traversée du pacifique à la rame
elle était partie mi-janvier du pérou il
ya plus de deux mois sur une coque de
noix de 7 mètres et demi
l'on musique la vie en rose ne me quitte
pas tout le monde connaît bien et voici
version jazz c'est le nouvel album de la
chanteuse américaine dee dee bridgewater
elle reprend les standards français il
avait le plr olivier robert
mon pays est parue
du michigan où elle a été élevée aux
sons d'ella fitzgerald vit à new york la
ville fétiche de 10 10 c'est paris tu ne
m'avais de fait 86 s'est passé vraiment
en france et à paris
mon rêve c'est de mourir en france est
d'être intérêts enterré apparaît un pied
sur chaque continent y compris dans son
répertoire
elle marche dans les traces de joséphine
baker
j'étais un peu notre façon de de rendre
hommage à justin baker et qui en même
temps de dire que je suis un peu comme
elle j'ai un peu j'ai un peu pris le
flambeau et puis un j'avance vers
l'avenir
rentré aux states surtout pour raisons
fiscales
diddy regrette la france elle s'attaque
donc au monument de la chanson française
j'ai d'arrangements jazzy très faim
qu'elle colporte de scène en scène
produire quoi bon des livres 2 entre
doyen poggia de sa puissance vocale
réinvente nos standards et en anglais ça
déménage
et mme tout et qu il prend mais sous fin
de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
tout de suite la météo nathalie rihouet
point route valérie maurice 20h55 envoyé
spécial guilaine chenu et françoise joly
12h45 dernier journal aise mettaient dès
6h30 et les matins au tour de william
leymergie à 13 heures benoît duquesne à
20 heures et le week-end vous
retrouverez béatrice schönberg pour
terminer les enfants ouvrez grand les
yeux voici un rêve un fantasme de pâques
le plus grand en chocolat jamais créé
huit mètres france 2 aux plus de 6
mètres de circonférence deux tonnes de
chocolat il a été présenté en belgique
difficile quand même a caché dans le
jardin à l'aise
votre soirée